[MUSIC]
Often when people think about leading
change or
implementing change in organizations, they
always think at the 30,000 feet.
They're very abstract.
They usually talk about generalities such
as, how do I communicate?
How do I engage?
How do I reach out to people?
But often, this 30,000 feet orientation
simply means that we're fighting
the campaign of leading change and
implementing change as an air war.
By contrast, if you really want to succeed
in embedding change within organizations,
thinking about it just as an air war is
not enough.
You really have to think about it as a
ground war.
And in order to fight that ground war,
which is going to be messy, which is going
to be surprise laden.
You've actually got to have, not only a
plan that gives you confidence, but
a plan that emphasizes flexibility.
[MUSIC]
PRESS is an acronym.
It consists of five letters.
Each letter denotes, if you will, a
sub-process of implementing change.
Remember, it's a sub-process and not a
stage.
That means you have to think of these five
sub-processes in tandem.
What does PRESS stand for?
The first sub-process is persuading.
Persuading has to do with, how do you
influence the emotions of people so
that you can change their beliefs, in the
hope that they will actually you know,
generate new behaviors that are much more
relevant to the organization.
The R in the PRESS framework stands for
recruiting support and overcoming
resistance.
Any worthwhile change will face
opposition.
Of course, individuals oppose change for a
variety of reasons.
But if we understand the target markets
behind change,
we can understand those individual
reasons.
And here,
we're much more concerned with how groups
of people can stymie and block change.
So we're interested, if you will, in the
network structure of resistance and
how to break open that resistance in
organizations.
The third element of the press framework
is E, and it is very important.
It's actually about energizing new
behavior.
A very powerful way in which we can change
the beliefs of
people is getting them to do things.
And energizing is all about getting people
to do things given how you supply them
information, given how you cleverly design
rewards, or empower individuals.
The other sub-process in the PRESS
framework is staffing.
Staffing actually has to do with, how do
you put together a change team?
And here, who should be on the change
team?
What does that actually convey in terms of
credibility of the change initiative, and
so forth?
And we'll talk about how the change team
may actually be related to
the executive committee or the executive
leadership of the enterprise, and
how various teams can bud off from the
change team
to implement sub-tasks that are part of
the overall change.
The final S, of course, is sequencing.
Sequencing has to do with the ordering of
the actions, and these actions may
have to do with persuading or energizing
or recruiting or staffing.
Figuring out when to do what is important.
So, what we'll actually focus on in the
sequencing module is,
what do we need to do before day one of
the change?
What do we need to do on day one?
What do we need to do by day ten, day 20?
We'll also build an opportunity for
review.
And if you have a plan like that, the
chief consequence is confidence.
But it'll also give you again, opportunity
for review and editing, and
then you can actually see how much of
persuasion do you want to emphasize,
how much of energizing do you want to
emphasize?
And what is it you want to do to ensure
that,
as you're implementing the change, there
is momentum rather than fatigue?
There is excitement rather than cynicism.
[MUSIC]